hi and welcome to episode number 19 of
the weekly Google club pass from podcast
I'm Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandela hey Mark hey
friends sku doing pretty good pretty
happy that I finally gcp next what is
over that was pre epic if that was I
think epic is actually the right word
for it yeah like awesome in the true
sense of the word yep there was lots of
lots of lots of lots of interviews yeah
but yeah actually uh what was your
favorite part man Oh things I think for
me I biased because we were sitting
right in the middle of the playground we
were um but the playground like I loved
the playground I was so happy to see so
many cool interactive things that people
could like look at from the data center
360 to the motor booth where they could
sort of interact with the vision API the
vision BOTS like just being able to see
people get hands-on with the stuff we
run at Google cloud platform and like
interact with it a really fun way I
think that was really rewarding i really
enjoyed that yeah that was actually lots
of fun we interviewed a bunch of people
from the instrument the the company that
helped us build those demos and it was
really amazing to the point that if you
go to our twitter page twitter.com slash
gcp podcast you'll see that we changed
our picture and now we we actually have
a picture taken with a motor boat yeah
yeah I think you might see that picture
show up in a few places once i integrate
it with a few more event services that
was an awesome picture yeah yeah no that
was great they asked us to show surprise
and i think we should surprise uh yeah
we were right we're very very good at
being surprised very much so very much
so but I know that key notes are pretty
amazing they're old yeah really great so
we've got for our listeners today I
think a bunch of interviews that we did
with speakers at the event should we
share the number of interviews we mean
it in a loop two days yeah as if you
weren't at the event we how many
interviews did we do it was 43 interview
something like that yeah so we
interviewed a whole bunch of people like
three minute five minute to minute
interviews at JCP next we had all that
gear there and it was just non-stop it
was it was pretty crazy it was a
very noisy environment so I wanted to
thank again Brian Dorsey for the amazing
equipment that allowed us to record all
the things we recorded and they actually
sound great yeah they sound great thanks
so much to everyone who came by at the
table sat down with us had a chat told
us about their experiences what they
were building they felt about the event
we're definitely I think gonna feed in a
bunch of content in two episodes past
this one for the next years or so yeah
probably until the next gcp NEX we're
just gonna roll it through yeah pretty
happy with how that turned out and
actually the cool thing of the week for
this week is going to be related to that
the main content of the week is going to
be related to that and then the question
of the week is going to be related to
that today it's a gcp next episode yeah
it's totally gcp next episode so yeah
main content we're going to be doing
interviews with speakers so we've got
five speakers or actually more than that
because we have some people yeah we have
five interviews with a bunch of speakers
exactly let me talk to them and then we
also have a question of the week from
someone who came by and talked to us at
the event as well yeah so what did the
goal thing of the week then so the cool
thing of the week finally enough gcp
related is we've released all the
youtube videos for gcp next so you're
very interested in the keynotes if
you're interested in any presentations I
might be in one of them yeah I actually
watched three of the talks already yeah
one was yours so where you talk about
dragons on the cloud which is pretty
awesome yep then just in back with p.m.
Google cloud platform that he does a lot
of know Jas talking about how to make
his noogler hat spin on through bits
like little bits yeah okay it wasn't
that sounds good it's very interesting
talk and yeah and then I actually like
I'm going to watch Julia Forelli stock
on how to train a neural networks to
know if something is huggable or not
that sounds really cool and we will be
talking to Julia and a little yeah we'll
be talking to Julie in a minute
excellent so if people listen to the
speaker interviews that are about to
come up and they want to see the
presentations they should be online and
all the other stuff to key notes from
some temperature from everyone else Eric
Smith
yes it was they're all online so you can
definitely check that out excellent so
shall we get started with the interviews
from a speakers sounds like a good idea
let's go for that so we're here with my
calves is hi Mike how are you doing very
good it's been a great show so far great
and you work for cloud technology
partners you know they're a boston-based
firm that helps companies get to the
cloud whether they're migrating apps or
building net new and we do a lot of work
on a Google platform very cool could you
tell us a little bit more about what
kind of products you use with them and
what kind of what is your favorite
product or the favorite product for your
customers actually well my personal
favorite is the whole big data
collection of things from nice you know
data flow pubs bigquery I mean most most
i've been working data warehousing my
whole life and the hardest part is
always getting the data in and google is
just you know a couple api's and a
couple configurations and that the hard
parts done and then you actually focus
on getting the results out of the data
that's a game changer mines very nice so
I'm assuming Europe you also work with
big table a little bit what do you think
I'll bet big tables quite a new product
how do you use it well I mean again in
my background data warehousing I
remember buying appliances like the
teaser cost millions of dollars and you
go dark for a year just setting up the
infrastructure and stuff and now you get
tools like bigquery big table and you
know you're just up and running and
getting results that are 10 times faster
we can get anyplace else it's just it's
just kind of amazing actually yeah
wantable and so I believe you're here at
JCP next you presented yeah I was on a
panel panel talking about cloud
migrations which is a kind of a new
chapter for for Google right i mean
riginal II it was all about you know
kind of the future of development you
know with all these high-level services
but i think the realization comes you
got to get people on a platform first so
now there's a big focus on cloud
migration we do a lot of work net space
right thing when you say cloud migration
is that specifically like moving from
one cloud provider to another what is
that really me but normally it's moving
from on-prem to the cloud and in the
biggest use case is always you know we
have 20 data center
we got to get to 3 by x date which is
usually very aggressive yeah so the good
is you know people are moving fast to
file the bat is lifting and shifting so
they're not getting advantage of the
cloud but that's that's the next way
once you get them there then you start
helping me architect their building at
noon various things so for people are
doing that shifting on lifting I'm
assuming that most of them did just move
to Google compute engine yeah so in a
lot of cases you can their time crunch
so it's get what I have in the cloud so
they're treating Google more like a
virtual datacenter yeah I say and
they're not they don't have the time yet
to take advantage of those higher-level
services and that's once you get them
there then you then you move them up to
stack so I put in the door type
situation yeah one when you say move out
of the stop the stack could you tell it
but more about that isn't I our
container engine or do you move them to
a pen to know how does a loaded term it
means so many things to many people
though I really mean is getting them to
use more high-value API so getting them
to use like Cooper Nettie's getting them
to use bigquery dataflow all those
services where you no longer have to
focus on the infrastructure in the
plumbing it kind of does it for you yeah
and then you can focus on building apps
and and doing the machine learning and
getting insights and stuff like that
yeah that it that is actually what earth
was mentioning during the keynote about
the server less architecture not because
there's no service but because you don't
really care about them anymore yeah it's
very interesting really moving up to
another level of it yeah and the only
challenge is most these enterprises are
just figure out what cloud is so you
start talking about surrealist stuff
that it dies just kind of glaze over and
it sometimes it takes them stumbling and
bumbling on the cloud for a couple years
so they they get it and start moving up
the value chain and taking high-level
services the copies have been in the
cloud for a while they get it and it
they're like salivating over you don't
do stuff like that so speaking of
keynote did you have a particular launch
or product or demo what was your
favorite part I like I like a lot of the
machine learning prediction stuff I like
that a lot of where we're getting a lot
of projects you know sometimes your
label IOT sometimes really late with big
data but there's a lot of companies who
are
harvesting sensor information and their
first step is just to get it all in one
place but their ultimate goal is what
can we learn from this data and how can
we offer new services how can we change
an industry or how can we change pricing
models so there are a lot of copies are
early net journey and you know we're
helping them get the data in one place
but it's nice to see where you know
because right now machine learning is an
art and a science yeah yeah and you're
trying to make that you know so any
developer sort of a commodity to that
yeah that I'm looking forward to that I
know there's a lot of work yet to do but
that that's good direction to be going
that is very cool did you get the chance
to put a little bit with the playground
activities our query and the photo booth
and so on no I actually been running
between sessions and we have a booth
here so I've been okay back and forth
between that but I do need to actually a
Tetris machine over there my efforts do
that yeah very cool well thank you so
much for being with us today yeah and
see you later alright appreciate it
thank you so much we are joined here by
niels provokes who is hot off the stage
from the keynote this morning uh how you
doing today Neal I'm doing just fine
glad that I'm done you know with my
obligations for the day that is good it
took a while to prepare yeah yeah I bet
it did you wanna give us like a really
quick 30 second synopsis or what you
just presented on stage sure so at
Google I'm responsible for security and
privacy engineering yep google has you
know spent many many years creating a
very very secure platform and so for gcp
customers were wondering you know what
does that mean for us so during the talk
I essentially said you know trust and
transparency is very important to us let
me explain to you how we have built
Google's infrastructure to be secure and
then relate to you what that means you
know as a customer for running on top of
TCP and so essentially started from the
bottom you know trusted hardware trusted
food you know cryptographic identities
for our jobs d-does protection you know
unfishable user identities with you know
how for a second factor and then gave
some examples of how customers can
leverage that on top of gcp for example
storage encryption happens by default
yeah for Google App Engine we give you
our cloud security scanner
to find vulnerabilities such as XSS or
mixed content Mick spinning and talk a
little bit about our efforts to secure
the TLS certificate infrastructure with
certificate transparency we have worked
for years to create a model where all
issued certificates can be verified in a
publicly available lock instead of just
you know ramp people through you know
the security stands they get yeah we're
running on gcp and some of the things
that we are thinking of giving them in
the future so for example we are working
on key management system and those kind
of things very cool that's a lot of
information so if anyone is more
interested the keynote was recorded and
you should definitely check that the
video i was actually checking it out
while we were here uh-huh it was a very
good presentation congratulations on
that there's a specific topic that we
get a question quite often which is ad D
dots right I get a little bit more where
is the daddy does protection coming and
taking place for Google cloud platform
so when you run on our platform you
essentially benefit from our serving
infrastructure network if you let's say
enable https load balancing that gets
served be an infrastructure that has d
does protection builder who actually
during the talk I you know got to share
a little bit that we have extended that
protection also the news and human
rights organization election monitoring
sites p.m. who seems like a timely topic
that was very good and I heard the
audience clapping to that they did I
thought expected that to be honest now
that's very cool and just just so we're
closer because this is something I'm
interested in is it specifically HTTPS
or do you have the same protection
unlike h1 so the load balancer you know
does HTTP and HTTPS but you know to be
perfectly honest look you know if you're
running on the internet these days it's
better protect yourself with TLS right
google has been pushing to you know
encrypt all of our traffic we have just
made the transparency report available
last year last week the sort of tracks
our progress and there's no excuse for
anybody and putting a website on the
internet not to use encryption
definitely coming from a responsible for
the security for Google cloud platform
sounds paid normal yeah right that's
good thank you so much for coming and
talking to yeah yeah so much for your
time
bye thank you we've been joined by two
speakers here at our table James Malone
and Francis Perry thank you very much
for joining us thank you nice to be here
how are you both doing today awesome
yeah doing was enjoying meeting people
wonderful so I know you were speaking
about some interesting stuff here at
just be next I just want to give us a
little bleep overview of what it is
you're talking about absolutely so we
gave a talk yesterday that was focused
on creating what we call next-generation
data processing where people don't have
to fight with infrastructure they don't
have to worry about using the multiple
tools to try and do batch from stream
processing and they can trust that their
data pipelines are going to be portable
a full-on JCP or between clouds or on
cloud non premise yeah we started with a
little history of MapReduce and sort of
how that new programming paradigm really
changed the way that we do data
processing and we talked about how that
diverges a little bit so inside Google
after that MapReduce paper was published
we continued innovating we had a lot of
new ideas that we kept doing but it was
this really homogeneous environment
right within Google we just have a few
file formats a few languages it's very
standardized tooling so we really went
deep on the right way to do data
processing and it but we were able to a
very deep because we were very
homogeneous whereas externally the
ecosystem looks very different they took
the MapReduce paper implemented it
Hadoop and then this whole ecosystem
flourished with all these diverse ideas
and now we've got basically two products
at gcp that build on that legacy Google
Cloud Data proc which is a managed spark
and Hadoop offering and then Google
Cloud dataflow which is our basically
next-generation way from writing
programs it's really going to combine
batch and streaming into into one API
very cool I gotta say that Google Cloud
dataflow is one of my favorite products
to the point thank you i will write java
for it like i never write java and so
far it's the only learned with today's
report is java city right up you can to
read your blogs my friend yesterday we
announced a python alpha support for
batch that is awesome the python SD kids
out there cuz we do all the development
in open source so it's out there i get
hub and now we have an alpha program for
service support provided on cloud
dataflow on the fully managed service I
know a lot of people that will be very
happy with that yeah yes you're one of
them I will be one of them i prefer
python it's still negot but it's better
than Java for me yeah that is awesome
well what we're really excited about
when we when we donated the data flow
model and these first two SDKs that we
developed to the apache software
foundation as this new incubating
project Apache bean the real goal behind
that is to put the framework out there
the programming model and then the
documentation that will allow other
developers who like other languages go
or Scala or Ruby or basically let people
add to this community and add new
languages and also new runners if you've
got a different distributed processing
back-end that you're a fan of you can
run beam pipelines on that right add
that capability into the into the system
very nice sear able to sort of leverage
that wider community did right oh we
live on that platform right very cool
good we're not moving more about uh the
other side of the big data not only
cloud dataflow but later all right i was
gonna say their proc yeah yeah I always
makes a toboggan data lapse for some
reason later proc why would you made it
I would you mix product names that have
data all in them you're obviously not
reading your google spy flash cards so
yeah club data proc is it's built around
a different set of open source tools so
in our talk session apprentice just
mentioned this the MapReduce paper kind
of set off two parallel streams and one
google ultimately led to cloud dataflow
and another was the open source
community took MapReduce paper created
just a whole ecosystem around so they
created Apache dupe patches park peg
hive there's probably 30 or 40 different
logos and quad a park is designed to
allow people to take advantage of that
open source ecosystem but it combines
that open source ecosystem with Google
cloud platform so instead of looking at
your mixer and there's like only a few
knobs on that and the open source
product usually has a couple hundred
dobbs piece and quantity proc is
designed to help people take advantage
of that stuff
without having to be an expert and buy a
ton of books and know exactly which
memory settings to do so I can pretty
much go to it be like okay it's gonna
give me some best practices and some
boxes to explain what certain things are
and then I can be like boop boop boop
and then ya see can we go you can go
guys do yeah yeah so yeah you can go and
create a cluster of like a hundred
computers all tie together and do some
awesomely parallel data crossing on them
that is awesome well thank you so much
for taking the time to talk to us today
yeah that one separately if you tutor
thank you thanks coming right off the
stage we have Julia frioli joining us
here at the table Julia how are you
doing today I'm well how are you mark
I'm very well princess how are you doing
I am great I'm actually I'm actually
very happy that Julie's here because
since we are here on the floor we are
not watching the talks and everyone that
I heard that when that went to your talk
was very excited about it and they said
it was amazing tell us a little bit
about it what did you talk about well so
yesterday at the keynote Jeff Dean
announced one of our new platforms which
is our machine learning platform cloud
machine learning and so my session dovin
to a little bit of the details
surrounding you know what machine
learning can do and what kind of
problems it can solve and how does it do
that so I believe one of the problems
you were looking at solving was
something to do with hugs yeah well you
know sometimes I like a sanity check
here in there telling me if I should
actually hug something or not speaking
you know I'm somebody who accidentally
hugged a cactus once so I'm intimately
familiar with things that you shouldn't
hug so what we were really trying to do
is is do an image classification problem
now the division API which is a part of
Google's machine learning platform does
things like identify what is in an image
but what it can't do is tell you if you
should hug it right naturally naturally
and that's a common problem I have as
well and yeah my hug ability is is a
very important feature right so what we
did was I actually sent out a survey to
my team
getting them to tell them tell me what
are examples of things that they would
or wouldn't hub I got some really
interesting answers back so I i went out
and i found example images of each of
those things i took about a hundred and
sixty images of things that people said
that they would hug and 160 that they
wouldn't hug and use to those to train a
classifier that we can use on any image
to give us some information about
whether or not it's a good idea to hug
that object so i'm curious what results
did you get at the end of it that we're
either more interesting or surprising
that you may not have been expecting
well okay so I I trained the the
classifier over things like puppies
kittens you know the usual suspects
clouds dandelions and pillows so these
were things that people said that they
would hug and it was really important to
get things that were organic and
inorganic right so that you get like a
nice spectrum um in the not hug category
we got things like sharks teeth broken
glass puffer fish and stuff like that
right so I I did two tests I uploaded a
picture of an octopus from an aquarium
now my classifier said no don't hug that
that you know maybe somebody said II too
many hugs as an error didn't actually
get that but you know months do the same
thing um but when I uploaded a picture
of an octopus that somebody had
crocheted so like a stuffed animal huh
octopus that like got a really nice
score saying yeah you should you should
hug that um and I just thought that was
absolutely fascinating right because
it's taking at a high level the same
subject but with a different
implementation yep and it's able to
differentiate between those two I
thought that was amazing very cool yeah
very cool so
neural network modeling the hug ability
Oh stuff that is that is amazing I don't
believe it's been done before I think
this might be new I'm I'm pretty sure it
is I gotta hurt but someone is like yeah
how huggable are things that's amazing
hmm yeah yeah yeah it's very cool uh so
yes we announced a lot of things about
machine learning yesterday but what was
your favorite announcement although the
machine learning of course oh my
favorite announcement yeah um well you
know since I started working on cloud
I've always been enamored with with
bigquery the first time I heard the the
architecture described to me I was like
wow this is a completely unintuitive to
me I would have never thought of this so
of course I love it um and and be it
just makes so much sense and it's
something that really takes the power of
what we're doing at Google and and
delivers it to everybody else so they
made some really cool announcements on
on price cuts and architecture with how
bigquery actually works yesterday and
I'm not an expert so I can't tell I
can't diagram it out for you in any way
this is the podcast so you can see it
anyway yep but um I think those might be
my other favorites of next very cool
well thank you so much really for being
here taking the time to talk to us today
thank you so much and looking forward to
the work towards that video to thank you
thank you okay so we're here we kneel
Palmer and Drakkar from FIS global and
they just came out of giving an amazing
talk uh so we wanted to interview a
little bit know a little bit how do
youhow who you are first yeah so why
don't you go first Neil sure FIS is the
world's largest financial services
technology firm we provide software for
everything from online banking to ATMs
through to asset management risk
surveillance for the big banks my
world's a little bit different we run an
incubator group where we look at
emerging technologies and figure out
what they're going to mean for our
business
very cool uh I work very closely with
Neil day to day and I'm a Java developer
scallop developer on the side well plug
computing you Nene very nice you tell us
a little bit how you use the cloud so we
were just up there talking about our bid
for the consolidated audit trail this is
the next generation stock market
reconstruction system that the SEC is
looking to book together one of the
issues with the current stock market and
the regulatory systems is there's a lot
of them it's very disparate it's kind of
hard for people to know what happens
when something goes wrong in the stock
market so this next system the goal is
to be able to do that very interesting
that you'd be able to actually not only
follow the market but actually
understand what goes on yeah so there
was a there was a what's called the
flash crash back in 2010 where several
trillion dollars were wiped off the US
markets and then serious nothing serious
and then it vanished and then
mysteriously reappeared which you know
at when I have trouble when that's 20
bucks out of my wallet several trillion
dollars and so this you know there are
still arguments happening today six
years later about what actually happened
and that's just it's not a good thing
for the well-ordered functioning of our
society and are you looking basically to
leverage the power of the cloud and like
certain aesthetic maybe compute maybe
machine learning other things that you
can expand that sort of power of
computers right so so we've been
partnered with Google from the get-go so
we're pretty much using every piece of
juicy p we were just announcing the
results of our new load test we
processed 25 billion fixed messages in
about 50 minutes and to end we hit peak
of about two reads thirty eight gigs a
second writes about 22 gigs a second
going through so it's pretty smoking
that is pretty amazing yeah and I assume
that's what you were talking about in
your session today that's right that's
right and so really it's our prototype
to say you know we can handle the level
of date you're talking you're talking
about the entire US market has to be
analyzed in four hours on a daily basis
whoo and so it's not it's not
insignificant very very cool so since
we're here I just be next
I'm assuming you you had a look at the
all the announcements the keynotes what
was your favorite part but what is the
announcement that you've got you the
most excited well I demoed you know some
visualization tools and I think there
was there was one they showed in the
keynote I don't remember the name but it
was a pretty brilliant visualization
tool for bigquery and I can definitely
go check that out very cool what about
you Neil I've been running some of the
security conversations are very
important to me and so some of the talks
from Neil Provost were great you know I
think I think I'm looking forward to not
just sort of the ongoing security
conversation with gcp but you know in an
ideal world you know what i want for
christmas is you guys to some expose
your tool chain around releasing
applications in gcp that would be
awesome it happens already with App
Engine but be kind of cool if some of
that stuff was was available for wider
use and there eric schmidt's you know
vision of the future for app development
was interesting so yeah it's maybe hey
was talking about Google three along
yeah that was really fun to watch
definitely gonna think there's some good
stuff on the horizon so it sounds like
you use a variety of Google cloud
platform tools at the moment if you had
to pick one that was your favorite which
one would you pick well if we don't say
big table Carter will killer ah but so
we love big table we love data flow yeah
well we got your of data flow because we
went from you know a year ago the
initial prototype used so the map are
natives a new distribution which was
fine was great but the dataflow stuff
just makes life so much easier the auto
scaling is a thing of joy to behold and
so we love that one what else ya now i
agree data flow all the way you know and
in this platform that's how we express
ourselves you know so very nice yeah and
anyway big table + data flow yeah that's
him you know we built this stuff it's
not like we've got a team of thousands
developers out there right we built we
build that in essentially a month with
the team of about six people that's
amazing yeah all right so very cool well
thank you so much for taking the time to
come here to talk to us anytime I'll
play junkie appreciate well thanks again
to all of those figures that took the
time to
by the Google cloud platform podcast
booth at gcb next well then that's a
mouthful thank you for taking the time
to go by talk to us and tell us a little
bit about what they were talking at what
they thought about the conference yep uh
one of the people that came talk to us
was not a not a speaker yeah he was
actually asking a question and we
decided that could be a great question
of the week yep so let's hear it yeah
sounds good so we're here we're romin
irani and he actually came to ask some
go questions so we decided that maybe
this could be the question of the week
excellent so hi Roman hi um go for it
what is your question yeah so my
question is about using go on App Engine
and you know in previous i've been using
App Engine with Java and other languages
and there's always been this restriction
that you can't use certain libraries and
App Engine has a fixed programming model
so when it comes to go are there any
restrictions for go on App Engine or
what would be certain scenarios in which
go on App Engine is probably preferred
compared to go on maybe compute engine
directly okay that's a very good
question so to answer the first part of
the question it which is what
restrictions do we have on go for a
pension they're pretty much the same
restrictions that you could find for
java on App Engine meaning that every
request has to be answered in less than
60 seconds you cannot write to the file
system directly and you cannot have
binary libraries basically it's you can
only run go and actually on top of that
you can use the unsafe package because I
the unsafe package is not really safe
hence the name there's also some
limitations in which is pretty similar
again in terms of like if you want to
make HTTP requests you have to use the
URL fetch library yeah and do some other
stuff like that but the URL the URL
library actually the girl fetch library
also provides an H decline if you nature
so adding to a great square well with
existing libraries if you can sir so for
the second part of the question which is
when good at use go on App Engine or on
compute engine what I could say is if
you're doing web server stuff I could
always go with a pension
and that's mainly because you're getting
all the scaling and 0 management for
free like you getting that automatically
which is really cool and if you have
something which is really similar to web
server but you need something specific
that it's a limit like for instance you
need to use Allinol regular expressions
and regular expressions you want
specific version graining see which is
something that we have then you will
need to move to manage VMs for instance
so you still have the that scalability
and the close to 0 management but your
but you are now using sea or the file
system or whatever you need and
otherwise yeah compute engine i could do
it when it's not really a web server
like if it's a worker doing something
like heavy processing and it takes a
long time and it's communicating through
pops up stuff like that even then you
could do that with managed VMs even
though you could do him but with managed
VM yeah if you really needed to so far
what when I what I do is I start with
App Engine by default and if I cannot
really do it on a pension but it's
really really told like a small thing
then I consider managed VMs otherwise if
it doesn't really match I will start
with compute engine but really quick
i'll move cut to container engine
because it's so much easier to manage I
hope can I just follow up with those
like yeah yeah go right from question
what about concurrency stuff on go so
try to run those things on a virgin how
does there is similar imitations on App
Engine there is a single thread for
running co routines on App Engine and
that's like just the one generally
speaking like from my experience it's
never really been a huge issue
especially for web stuff like it's not
like you're going to be doing that much
stuff if you needed to expand upon that
and yet start looking to go further down
that abstraction pathway to go to manage
VMs yeah I could say that the biggest
restriction is that you can only run one
thread but that doesn't mean you can
only run one girl routine you can run as
many go routines that you need apps are
important thing is that you all the girl
routines will be stopped when the HTTP
handler finishes so you can have one
girl within they started by the handler
and keeps on running for
one hour that's not something that we
allow yeah but then you just use task
queues yeah then you can use task using
and then in task use you again you can
use as many co routines as you want so
yeah good thank you thank you so much
thanks for joining us thanks to romin
irani for coming by the booth and asking
such an interesting question we got to
have a really good chat about it and go
related I always go related to them
expense that's very very happy excellent
um so I know is that as of this podcast
recording i will be at strata i'll be
hoping running the code labs there so if
you're listening to the podcast and at
that event please swing by and say hello
i would love to say hi i'll be wearing
my google cloud platform podcast t-shirt
too oh yeah but if you're a listener we
actually now have t-shirts I mean maybe
if you find this at some event will be
able to provide you with some yeah
they're really go limited-edition
limited-edition totally yeah are you
gonna be anywhere special anytime soon
uh not really i'm gonna i'm gonna go to
DEFCON which is a conference for deb
brothers developer relations engineer by
or engineers and in san francisco nice
so uh so that's gonna be like five
minutes walking I like those strips that
sounds good let me know how that good
yeah it's gonna be fun awesome no that's
great well if people want to get in
contact with us where can they go Fran
Cesc oh I know those uh so we are on
Twitter we free active on Twitter so
it's GC podcast yep we are also on
google plus at plus GZ podcast yep we
are also on reddit on the subreddit R /
just podcast yep we are also we have a
web page yeah geez vodkas calm yep and
an email hello at JC podcaster come yep
and I think I'm not forgetting any now
you are slack oh yeah on the gcp also
it's like yeah yes we communities like
we're at a hash podcast and what is the
URL to access that if people want to
join slack the URL is bit ly slashing
gcp luck that's the inviter that they
can go in on and they'll be able to
connect from there awesome and yeah
we've actually been receiving more
emails for recently we're very happy
about
that we're going to be answering some of
the questions of the wheat that you sent
us next episodes don't worry about that
definitely well thank you very much for
joining me Francis thank you very much
for joining me today and joining me
during gcb next that was an awesome
experience it was absolutely fantastic
and I'll see you next week
you